Hi,
perhaps you are viewing this video because you are in fact looking for a last
minute gift.
Perhaps you also know someone to whom you would like to give that gift.
Who's familiar with my work.
You might also be aware that I have a new book coming out on March 3rd,
2021 beyond order 12 more rules.
For life.
Beyond order can be pre-ordered. At many booksellers,
you can find a list of them by country and corporation.
On my website, Jordan B peterson.com.
The more precise URL is listed in the video's description.
If you would like to pre-order this book as a gift,
you can download and print out a one page purchase announcement PDF
indicating that you have done.
So that could be slid inside an envelope and delivered to the person to
whom the pre-order delivery has been scheduled.
The PDF can be found@jordanbpeterson.com as well,
and a more precise URL for that is also in the video description.
So to recapitulate, you need to buy a gift. You know,
someone interested in my work,
you pre-order the book from a bookseller listed on my website and have it
delivered as a gift.
You print out the purchase announcement on my website and send it to the gifts.
Eventual recipient here is a one paragraph selection
from beyond order.
This is from the first chapter rule one do not casually
denigrate social institutions or creative achievement.
It's from a section called the utility of the fool.
It is useful to take your place at the bottom of a hierarchy.
It can aid in the development of gratitude and humility,
gratitude. There are people whose expertise exceeds your own,
and you should be wisely pleased about that.
There are many valuable niches to fill given the many complex and serious
problems that we must solve.
The fact that there are people who fill those niches with trustworthy skill and
experience is something for which to be truly thankful,
humility.
It is better to presume ignorance and invite learning than to assume sufficient
knowledge and risk the consequent blindness.
It is much better to make friends with what you do not know than with what you
know, because there is an infinite supply of the former,
but an all to finite stock of the ladder.
When you are tightly boxed in or cornered all too often by your own stubborn and
fixed adherence to some unconsciously worshiped assumptions,
all there is to help you is what you have not yet.
Yeah, learned.
So that's a sample paragraph beyond order.
Which can be pre-ordered now from the booksellers on my website.
And if you like given as a gift, uh,
thank you. Happy holidays.